et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis new york avec chadwick mot aux
journalistes politiques c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
bonsoir schalwyk mort merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france trois
semaines d'audience mais derek chauvine
à l'accusé reste silencieux
définitivement son silence peut-il le
desservir ou au contraire ça peut être
une stratégie payante
il est possible que les accusés ne
viennent pas à la barre lors de ces
procès du commun je n'y accorde pas trop
d'importance
la défense un cas très solide
cette affaire a tout changé l'année
dernière on était en première page de
tous les journaux l'est toujours
aujourd'hui
et pourtant on n'entend pas beaucoup
parler de ce qui se passa dans la salle
d'audience seul dans les journaux dans
les organes de presse les plus libéraux
de gauche ce qui semble indiquer que le
montage se passe plutôt bien pour
l'échauffement décrit ce procès comme un
procès très fort en émotions les experts
de la défense ont avancé des arguments
percutants
le procureur doit prouver beaucoup
d'éléments ils doivent prouver qu'il y
avait une intention de tuer un cash flow
il se trouvait que derek chauvin n'a pas
agi la fonction des protocoles policiers
il faut prouver que ses actions ont le
népal a marre de cet homme et qui ne
s'est pas agi d'une conjonction de
drogue
stress et d'autres problèmes donc c'est
compliqué nous allons croire que le
système de la justice est aveugle il
suffit qu'un jury quand je leur ai dit
ce que je t'aime et on sait gérer ne
sont cependant pas complètement détachée
du contexte politique à regarder la
réaction
regardez les forces les courants qui
veulent voir des règles chauvin prison
je ne sais pas si beaucoup de jurés
pourraient le courage d'être la personne
qui dit cet homme et qui ne s'en témoin
pour la défense ont vu leurs raisons et
wanda musée matthew watson député du
congrès américain a demandé à ce qu'il y
ait davantage de manifestations que
l'association ça plus d'éthique
donc il ya beaucoup de pression sur ces
jurés et il te libère en ce moment
chaque big man en tout cas vous de la
france c'est vrai qu'on a vu des images
assez insoutenable de cet homme
d'ailleurs je vous rappelle les mots du
procureur il a supplié jusqu'à ce qu'il
ne puisse plus parler on rappelle qu un
pneumologue a écarté la thèse de la
défense selon laquelle il serait mort
d'une arythmie cardiaque même le chef de
la police de minneapolis a déclaré que
son ancien agent avait violé les règles
qu'est ce qui vous permet aujourd'hui de
dire que la défense sont dans une
mauvaise posture
cela repose sur l'intention les
officiers ça avec tous leurs mouvements
sont enregistrés ils portent des caméras
autour de la foule a également deux
meira il ya des caméras dans la rue et
ce sont ces caméras il faut se demander
y avait-il une attention de ne pas fumer
quand je floyd il officiait comme
sept-îles à genval
alors que savaient que leur acte été
enregistré si ce n'était pas leur
intention c'est considérer qu'ils
agissaient en fonction des règles
conformément à son bras de fer alors
c'est une autre affaire et il ya des
experts qui ont parlé de cela tout comme
il ya des experts qui ont parlé de la
cause du décès des experts ont également
débattu sur la saturation d'oxygène dans
son lieu sans qui est très élevé pour
une personne qui aurait été asphyxiés
lisez je ne peux pas respirer je ne peux
pas respirer avant même que l'officier
le touch2 experts a dit que la police
est formé pour comprendre que si
quelqu'un dit je ne peux pas respirer
alors cette personne peut respirer car
il est impossible de parler lorsqu'on ne
peut pas respirer
donc ces officiers d'après leur
formation penser qu'ils agissaient de
manière tout à fait légale
pardonnez moi de vous couper parce que
effectivement ça peut être un point de
vue qui n'est pas forcément qui fait pas
forcément l'unanimité mais effectivement
c'est une opinion voilà que qu'on peut
entendre
il n'empêche qu'on pense l'opinion
publique aux etats-unis vous l'avez dit
c'est un procès minam en politique très
sulfureux bien évidemment le procès de
l'année nous avait même dit l'opinion
publique américaine
elle va dans quel sens je pense que le
pays en général et tout aussi divisés
que les notre échiquier politique entre
la gauche et la droite
l'opinion
des institutions médiatiques des
journalistes du parti démocrate et de
beaucoup d'autres institutions d'autres
organes de puissants et que derek
chauvin est coupable ils veulent qu'il
soit déclaré coupable et il fonce que
c'était un incident a fondée sur un
motif de racisme que la couleur de la
personne a mené soit une station donc à
sa mort il a déclaré innocent alors je
pense qu'il faut se préparer à du ko à
des troubles
et s'il est déclaré coupable alors y
aura également des manifestations c'est
très difficile à prédire
ce sujet politique et c'est un sujet
politique pour beaucoup de personnes
le pays est fortement fracturé entre
ceux qui pensent qu'ils devraient être
déclarés innocents et ceux qui le
croient coupable
merci chanuc mort d'avoir été avec nous
donc